bonjour à tous !
Une vidéo un petit peu particulière, aujourd'hui,
puisque je vais la faire
pour réagir un peu à chaud
à une actualité brûlante,
celle des ondes gravitationnelles
dont vous avez probablement pas
échappé à la nouvelle.
On vient d'annoncer, pour la première fois,
la découverte d'ondes gravitationnelles.
Donc ce que je voudrais faire,
dans cette vidéo,
c'est expliquer, un petit peu,
finalement qu'est-ce que c'est
et puis comment on a fait
pour les détecter et pourquoi c'est important.
Donc ça va être une vidéo qui est
un petit peu plus informelle, un petit peu moins léchée
que d'habitude mais voilà,
c'est l'histoire de tester aussi un nouveau format.
Alors pour comprendre ce que c'est
que les ondes gravitationnelles,
en fait, il faut repartir de la manière
dont on conçoit la force de gravité.
Alors la force de gravité, quand on l'apprend
par exemple au lycée,
on l'apprend avec la loi de Newton.
Donc c'est une loi qui donne l' intensité de la force
de gravité qui s'exerce entre deux objets massifs.
Et cette force dépend des masses des objets,
elle est proportionnelle aux masses des objets.
Et puis elle dépend comme
l'inverse du carré de leur distance.
Alors c'est pas très très important de retenir
la forme exacte de la loi qui donne cette force.
Ce qui est intéressant de constater
avec cette force-là,
c'est qu'en fait, tel que l'avait proposé Newton,
c'est une force qui se transmet
de manière instantanée.
C'est-à-dire que si jamais
on a deux masses comme ça
et puis qu'on imagine que soudainement
l'une des masses disparaît
ou bien change subitement de trajectoire,
dans la vision de Newton, en fait,
l'information que la force a changé
se transmet instantanément à l'autre masse.
Alors ça, c'est quand même conceptuellement
un petit peu étrange.
Faut quand même remarquer que,
à part cette petite bizarrerie conceptuelle,
la loi de Newton,
c'est un truc qui marche vachement bien.
Elle a été formulée
il y a peut-être presque 350 ans
et on continue de l'utiliser tous les jours.
Elle permet de prédire la trajectoire
des boulets de canon
et aussi la trajectoire des astres, par exemple.
Enfin, c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui marche formidablement bien.
Euh...
Mais y'a quand même
cette petite bizarrerie conceptuelle
qui est que si on croit cette loi,
y'a une espèce d'information qui voyage instantanément
quand la force se modifie.
Alors si on regarde, en fait,
il y a une autre force
qui, comme on l'apprend au lycée,
se comporte un petit peu de la même manière,
c'est la force electrostatique.
Elle est donnée par la loi de Coulomb
qui ressemble énormément à la loi de Newton.
Au lieu d'avoir des masses,
on a des charges électriques.
Vous savez peut-être que la force électrostatique,
on l'a ensuite remplacée par quelque chose
de plus efficace, de plus riche
qui est l'électromagnétisme.
Donc la force électrostatique avait ce même défaut
qu'a la loi de Newton
de supposer que, plus ou moins ,
l'information se transmet instantanément à distance.
Et ça, ça a été guéri par
l'électromagnétisme
puisque l'électromagnétisme est quelque chose
de plus complexe
- je vais pas vous faire
un cours sur l'électromagnétisme -
L'électromagnétisme, en gros,
prend en compte le fait
que l'information prend
un certain temps à voyager,
notamment sous la forme
d'ondes électromagnétiques
qui voyagent à la vitesse de la lumière.
En fait, la lumière,
c'est une onde électromagnétique.
et donc l'électromagnétisme qui,
quelque part, remplace et complète
la force électrostatique de Coulomb,
permet de résoudre ce paradoxe.
Alors naïvement, on pourrait penser
qu'il va se passer la même chose avec la gravité
que ce qui s'est passé
avec l'électrostatique.
C'est-à-dire qu'on va remplacer
la loi de Newton
par un truc qui est plus riche,
plus compliqué
et qui fait intervenir des ondes
qui peuvent se propager.
En fait, la réalité, c'est quand même
quelque chose de plus compliqué que ça.
La loi de Newton a été supplantée,
si on peut dire,
en 1915, par la théorie
de la relativité générale d'Einstein.
Cette théorie d'Einstein,
c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est beaucoup beaucoup plus compliqué
que l'électromagnétisme.
La relativité générale, c'est pas juste
l'électromagnétisme adapté à la gravité.
C'est quelque chose
de beaucoup plus compliqué
qui suppose notamment que la force de gravité
provient de la courbure de l'espace-temps.
Alors ça, c'est très bien et il faut savoir
que la théorie de la relativité générale,
aussi complexe et mystérieuse qu'elle soit,
a été vérifiée expérimentalement
de plein de manières différentes.
Elle fait un certain nombre
de prédictions qui sont différentes
des prédictions de la théorie de Newton.
Et la plupart de ces prédictions
ont été vérifiées expérimentalement.
On peut citer, par exemple, le fait
que les corps massifs dévient la lumière.
Ce qui a été vérifié.
On peut citer les trous noirs.
On peut citer le big bang
- l'expansion de l'univers -
Le fait que dans un champ gravitationnel intense
le temps ne s'écoule pas de la même manière.
Voilà, tout ça, c'est des prédictions
de la relativité générale.
Mais ce qui est un petit peu étonnant
c'est que y'a un domaine de la relativité générale
où on n'a pas réussi encore à faire
de validation expérimentale forte.
C'est le domaine où les courbures
de l'espace et du temps sont faibles.
En fait, ce qui se passe
quand on prend la relativité générale
dans un domaine
où les courbures sont faibles,
elle se simplifie beaucoup
et on retrouve une théorie
qui ressemble un peu à l'électromagnétisme.
C'est-à-dire qu'on retrouve une théorie
dans laquelle il y a des ondes.
Des ondes qui se propagent
et c'est ça qu'on appelle les ondes gravitationnelles.
Donc les ondes gravitationnelle, en gros,
c'est ce qui se passe
quand on fait de la relativité générale
dans un espace-temps qui est peu courbé.
Ça peut paraître un peu bizarre
mais il faut savoir que  l'espace-temps
autour de nous est peu courbé.
Finalement, dans la relativité générale, on aime bien
les situations extrêmes comme les trous noirs
mais il faut bien voir que la quasi-totalité de l'univers
est un truc pas du tout extrême,
en fait très peu courbé.
Or dans un espace-temps
très peu courbé,
la théorie de la relativité générale prédit
qu'on doit avoir des ondes gravitationnelles.
Alors que sont les ondes gravitationnelles ?
Car il est important de visualiser
de quoi il s'agît.
On a dit que la relativité générale
décrivait la force de gravité
au moyen de la courbure
de l'espace-temps.
Donc une onde gravitationnelle, qui provient de la RG,
est une onde de déformation de l'espace-temps
- en quelque sorte une onde de courbure -
Ces ondes ont une structure assez particulière
que je vais essayer de vous représenter.
En fait, quand une onde gravitationnelle
avance et passe à travers un objet,
elle fait ça.
Ce qui veut dire que quand une onde gravitationnelle
passe travers un objet;
elle va dilater l'objet dans un sens
et le contracter dans l'autre
et ensuite
le recontracter dans ce sens-là
et le dilater dans le sens opposé.
Voilà, un onde gravitationnelle
qui se propage fait ça.
Alors un truc important pour savoir
comment on peut faire
pour détecter des ondes gravitationnelles,
c'est déjà de savoir qu'est-ce qui en émet.
Alors a priori,
à peu près n'importe quoi peut
émettre des ondes gravitationnelles.
Le problème, c'est que les ondes
gravitationnelles,
c'est un truc qui est fabuleusement faible.
Et donc, si on veut avoir une chance
de détecter des ondes gravitationnelles,
il faut se placer dans un cas où on est
en train de regarder des événements assez violents.
Notamment ce qui émet des ondes gravitationnelles,
c'est des corps massifs
qui sont fortement accélérés.
Alors dans l'univers,
la situation qu'on connaît le mieux
de corps massifs
qui sont très fortement accélérés,
c'est le cas de 2 étoiles
qui se tournent autour
On appelle ça, parfois, un binaire.
Et notamment les cas les plus extrêmes,
c'est quand ces étoiles sont très très lourdes,
par exemple les étoiles à neutrons,
qui sont, en quelque sorte,
des cadavres d'étoiles
voire carrément des trous noirs.
Donc quand des étoiles à neutrons
ou des trous noirs se tournent autour,
étant très massifs et très accélérés,
ils émettent des ondes gravitationnelles.
Alors, c'est quand même pas suffisant
parce que dans le temps normal de leurs rotations
ça reste trop faible
pour qu'on puisse les détecter.
Le seul truc qu'on a l'espoir de
détecter c'est le moment
où on est très proche de la collision.
Donc quand on a deux astres
qui se tournent autour, qui sont très massifs
et qui tournent très vite,
au moment où ils s'apprêtent
à rentrer en collision,
c'est là qu'il y a une bouffée d'ondes gravitationnelles plus élevée que la plupart du temps
et qu'on a une chance de détecter.
Or, jusqu'à aujourd'hui, on a jamais détecté
de telles ondes.
Alors la seule preuve dont on dispose,
c'est une preuve indirecte.
Un jour, deux astronomes ont repéré
un de ces binaires
et ont remarqué qu'il perdait de l'énergie.
Et une fois tout vérifié,
le seul moyen de justifier
cette perte d'énergie
a été d'imaginer qu'il émettait
des ondes gravitationnelles
et qu'il avait perdu une partie de ce son énergie
sous la forme d'OG.
Mais ça, c'était en quelque sorte, une preuve indirecte
de l'existence des OG.
Et d'ailleurs, les deux astronomes ont eu le prix Nobel
pour cette découverte.
Mais ça reste une preuve indirecte.
Visiblement, on a un phénomène et on ne l'explique
qu'avec les OG.
On ne les a pas vues directement.
Donc toute la question est de savoir
comment peut-on directement détecter ces ondes
de déformation de l'espace-temps.
En fait, ce qui est très compliqué,
c'est que ces ondes provoquent des déformations
ridiculement petites.
En gros, pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur,
si on prenait une barre d'un mètre de long
et qu'elle soit traversée par une OG.
la longueur de la barre varierait d'à peu près
dix puissance moins 19 mètres ( 10^(-19)m )
Donc un variation fabuleusement plus petite
que la taille d'un atome.
Ce qui veut dire que détecter
des variations de longueur dues aux OG
semble quasiment impossible.
Alors la méthode qu'on utilise
pour avoir un espoir de les voir quand même,
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'interférométrie.
C'est une méthode optique qui permet de repérer
de très petites variations de distance.
Le principe est le suivant :
on prend un laser
et on sépare son faisceau en deux.
que l'on envoie
dans deux directions perpendiculaires.
et puis on fait parcourir
à chacun des deux faisceaux, une certaine distance.
On place un miroir et on les fait revenir.
et quand les deux faisceaux
reviennent et se rerencontrent,
on obtient ce qu'on appelle
une figure d'interférence,
un truc un petit peu caractéristique,
on voit des franges lumineuses qui alternent
avec des franges sombres.
Cequi est amusant, c'est que
- alors c'est un dispositif qu'on peut faire,
par exemple en TP de physique -
-en 1ère ou en 2ème année
à l'université -
-Il suffit d'avoir un laser et des miroirs -
on peut se rendre compte
que si on déplace
un miroir d'une toute petite distance,
par exemple 100 nanomètres,
ça se voit tout de suite sur la figure
d'interférence
parce qu'elle bouge.
En fait,
l'interférométrie, c'est une méthode
qui permet de mesurer des variations de distance
de manière très très fine,
très très précise.
Le seul problème,
c'est que je viens de vous dire en gros
qu'avec un tel montage interférométrique
on peut très facilement repérer
des variations de 100 nanomètres.
Je vous ai dit, tout à l'heure,
qu'une barre d'un mètre
n'allait pas varier de 100 nanomètres
sous l'effet d'une OG.
Elle va varier de 10^(-10) nanomètres.
Que peut-on faire
pour espérer détecter cette variation ?
Alors la solution qu'on a trouvée
est de faire un interféromètre géant.
C'est quoi exactement ?
Et bien, c'est le même principe
que je viens de décrire.
On sépare un faisceau laser en deux.
Mais au lieu de parcourir un mètre jusqu'au miroir
et de revenir,
il parcourt 5 km.
Donc voilà le principe
des interféromètres géants.
Y'en a essentiellement deux.
Deux collaborations ont été montées
pour de tels interféromètres.
La collaboration VIRGO
qui est plutôt européenne
et puis la collaboration LIGO
qui est plutôt américaine.
Donc le principe est d'envoyer un faisceau laser
dans 2 tubes de 5 km de long,
dans lesquels on a fait le vide.
On les fait revenir
et on les fait interférer.
Mais, en fait, on ne se limite pas à cela.
Pour gagner encore un plus de distance,
ils font plusieurs allers-retours dans le tube
- 75, il me semble. -
Ainsi on récupère une figure d'interférence.
L'espoir est donc
si jamais une OG passe,
cette figure d'interférence doit
un petit peu bouger,
d'une valeur pouièmesque,
mais ça peut être la signature du passage d'OG.
Alors, la 1ère collaboration : LIGO
a débuté en 2002
et a fonctionné jusqu'en 2010.
Donc afin de détecter des choses aussi infimes,
il avait été calculé
que vu la sensibilité du montage
et puis vu la probabilité que, dans une région
proche de nous,
il y ait un binaire
sur le point d'entrer en collision,
on avait peut-être 1 chance sur 10
de détecter des ondes gravitationnelles,
avec ce montage.
Le grand changement apparu
entre 2010 et 2015
est dû au fait que le montage LIGO
a beaucoup été amélioré,
notamment pour sa sensibilité.
Et du fait de l'amélioration de cette sensibilité,
les gens qui font tourner cette manip
avaient estimé qu'on pourrait voir
beaucoup plus d'événements
et même une probabilité de voir
plusieurs événements chaque année,
puisque le montage est devenu
beaucoup plus sensible.
Et la nouvelle expérience - Advanced LIGO
ou Extended LIGO, je sais plus -
a commencé à tourner
en septembre 2015
et donc visiblement, ils ont eu du bol
parce que ça a très vite marché
et qu'ils ont repéré quelque chose.
Alors il y a une grande question là-dedans :
comment être sûr qu'on a bien repéré des OG ?
En fait, on a fait plusieurs choses
mais le plus important
- les gens de LIGO sont malins -
a été de construire
non pas un interféromètre
mais deux.
Un en Louisiane
et l'autre dans l'état de Washington,
un peu plus au nord.
Donc quand un événement d'OG
est supposé arriver,
on est censé le voir
sur les deux interféromètres
avec juste tout petit décalage temporel
qui correspond au temps qu'il faut à l'onde
pour voyager d'un détecteur à l'autre
Et donc dans ce cas précis,
ça a été un des moyens de vérifier
qu'on avait pas détecté
juste du bruit ou des fluctuations.
L'événement a bien été observé
sur les deux détecteurs.
Et à partir de la caractéristique de l'événement,
on peut remonter au scénario
du binaire qui a généré ces ondes.
Visiblement, ils ont pu déduire
que le binaire, à l'origine de ce cette bouffée d'OG,
a été formé par deux trous noirs
qui se tournaient autour
et de fusionner, en fait,
- car c'est vraiment le moment
qui précède la fusion qu'on voit -
et que ces trous noirs avaient des masses
de l'ordre de quelques dizaines de fois celle du soleil.
Voilà, il semblerait que, pour la première fois,
on ait vraiment détecté directement des OG
Est-ce vraiment important ?
Oui, c'est clairement important
et pour évacuer tout de suite
la question du prix Nobel,
si cela est avéré
et que l'équipe a réellement détecté
des ondes gravitationnelles,
un jour, sans aucun doute - peut-être pas en 2016 -
ils auront le prix Nobel.
Il faut voir que les OG sont vraiment
la pièce manquante
au puzzle de la relativité générale.
Je vous ai dit que la relativité générale
fait un certain nombre de prédictions.
Toute ces prédictions ont été vérifiées
sauf les ondes gravitationnelles.
C'était vraiment
la dernière pièce du puzzle.
Alors, en quelque sorte, on peut un peu
comparer ça à la découverte, en 2012,
du boson de Higgs.
C'était vraiment la pièce manquante
de la physique des particules.
On avait la théorie.
Tout, dans la théorie, avait été vérifié
dans les accélérateurs de particules
sauf le boson de Higgs.
Donc là, on est vraiment un peu
dans le même genre de situation.
Mine de rien,
moi, je trouve ce genre de découvertes
quelque part un petit peu triste.
On a une prédiction théorique
et on construit une manip énorme
- sur le plan expérimental,
c'est un truc de folie -
Puis, au final, on arrive
à vérifier la théorie
- donc c'est super -
mais du point de vue de la physique,
c'est presque un peu fade.
Y'a pas de surprise.
J'avais eu le même sentiment
au moment de la découverte
du boson de Higgs.
Je m'étais dit :
ok, c'est bien, on a trouvé
mais c'est un peu triste
parce que, quand on fait de la physique,
on aime bien être surpris.
On dit souvent que
la phrase la plus intéressante
quand on fait de la science,
c'est pas : " Eureka, j'ai trouvé ! ",
c'est : " Tiens, ça c'est bizarre ! "
Voilà, là visiblement,
rien de bizarre n'a été trouvé.
Tout semble marcher
comme sur des roulettes.
Donc oui, c'est clairement
une très très grande découverte
mais ça vous laisse toujours sur votre faim
parce que, finalement,
on a seulement vérifié la théorie
et c'est quand même toujours sympa
quand les expériences amènent des choses bizarres
qui viennent ensuite stimuler
un peu le le cerveau des théoriciens.
Voilà, donc j'espère que cette petite histoire
vous aura permis d'y voir un peu plus clair
sur cette question
des ondes gravitationnelles
Dans les mois à venir, y'aura probablement
des choses nouvelles qui seront annoncées
parce que si le détecteur LIGO
est si sensible que ça,
il est vraisemblable
qu'au cours des mois qui viennent,
il puisse détecter d'autres événements.
Donc, de toute façon, on saura très vite
si l'expérience est invalidée,
ce qui semble peu probable
ou bien si maintenant on est capable
de détecter régulièrement des OG.
Voilà, merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo !
C'était un format un petit peu différent,
vous aurez remarquer,
quelque chose de pas très léché,
quelque chose un peu plus informel.
J'espère que ça vous a plu.
Je le referai, peut-être, pour des actualités brûlantes, comme celle-ci.
Voilà, n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous en avez pensé
dans les commentaires,
si ce type de format vous plaît
et puis je vous retrouve, de toute façon,
très bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos
dans un format plus classique.
Voilà, merci et à bientôt !